hey everybody Chuck nice here from
Startalk and I'm sitting here with Shana
Gifford and Neil deGrasse Tyson and
we're inviting you to head over to the
origin channel on YouTube originals and
subscribe because Origen the original
sci-fi thriller from YouTube is coming
on November 14th and you'll be able to
catch us talking about deep space travel
and living on X so we're breaking it
down we are breaking it down yeah we're
gonna we're gonna break it down in
always necessary so you can fully
embrace the storytelling of origin right
and we could talk about because she's
here and because he's here not because
I'm here no she's actually tried to do
some of the things that anyone and I did
not die there you go so find out how you
won't die you head into deep space
travel click here subscribe
mm-hmm you will survive it